ashley va a comprar jugo y refresco con
una relación de 3 a 2 es una tabla para
ver las opciones de cuánto comprar de
cada pepita y bueno este es un problema
clásico de razones o proporciones tener
una relación o una razón de 3 a 2
es lo mismo que pensar en una proporción
de 3 medios es decir que por cada tres
juegos que ella compren va a comprar dos
refrescos así que esta información vamos
a utilizarla para llenar esta tabla lo
primero que vamos a hacer es poner este
dato que me dan dice que por cada tres
galones de jugo que ella compra va a
comprar dos galones de refresco esa es
la información que me da el problema
ahora para llenar estos otros dos
espacios habrá que fijarnos en lo
siguiente qué es lo que está pasando con
esta razón para que la razón se
conserven habrá que multiplicar por lo
mismo tanto en la cantidad de jugo como
la cantidad de refresco y así mantenerla
en este caso está comprando 12 galones
de jugo cuántos de refresco comprarán y
para eso date cuenta de lo siguiente si
a esta cantidad la estoy multiplicando
por cuatro para llegar al 12 3 por 4 es
12 si quieres que se mantenga la razón
habrá que multiplicar a este 2 por la
misma cantidad es decir 2 galones lo voy
a multiplicar por 4 para que se mantenga
la razón dos por cuatro me da porque 3
por 4 me da 12 y 2 por 4 por la misma
cantidad
me da 8 ahora para llegar a este número
que tenemos aquí date cuenta que ahora
estamos utilizando la información de los
galones de refresco si quiero comprar 12
galones de refresco cuántos galones de
jugo tengo que comprar para seguir con
la razón de 3 a 2 y para eso hay que
darnos cuenta que estoy multiplicando al
2 por 6 para llegar al 12 y por lo tanto
sí
quiero mantener la razón habrá que
multiplicar a este 3 por la misma
cantidad 3 por 6 me da 18 así que ya
está aquí la tabla está llena lo único
que quiero decirte es que la razón 3 a 2
es exactamente lo mismo que pensar en la
razón 3 entre 2 y 2 entre 8 y 18 entre
12 todas éstas representan la misma
razón así que vamos a comprobar esta
respuesta y vamos al siguiente problema
el siguiente problema es este esta tabla
muestra razones equivalentes a 7 4
completa los valores que faltan bueno
pues este problema es muy parecido si yo
me fijo que tengo la razón 7 a 4 y
quiero buscar una razón equivalente
habrá que multiplicar por la misma
cantidad en este caso este 7 lo estoy
multiplicando por tres y me da 21 si
quiero una razón equivalente habrá que
multiplicar a este 4 por la misma
cantidad
4 x 3 me da 12 12
la razón de 7 a 4 es la misma que la
razón de 21 a 12 ahora vayamos con la
siguiente fila al 4 porque lo
multiplicamos para llegar al 16 bueno
pues lo multiplicamos por cuatro así que
si quiere una razón equivalente al 7
habrá que multiplicarlo por la misma
cantidad 7 por 4 me da 28 así que ya
tengo otra fila la razón 28 16 es la
misma que la razón 7 a 4 porque
mantenemos la proporción al 7 porque lo
tenemos que multiplicar para que me dé
84 bueno pues 84 entre 7 es lo mismo que
12 si al 7 lo estoy multiplicando por 12
para llegar al 84 al 4 habrá que
multiplicarlo por la misma cantidad 4
por 12 es 48 por lo tanto la razón 84 a
48 es la misma que la razón
a 4 son razones equivalentes porque
estamos multiplicando por la misma
cantidad así que es hora de comprobar la
respuesta
y vamos al siguiente problema las
compañeras de viena comer brócoli y
coliflor a una razón de 12 a 7 este
problema está muy padre diana es una
tabla para mostrar las posibilidades de
cuánto brócoli y cuánta coliflor podría
comprar bueno pues ahora date cuenta que
en esta tabla
no tenemos escrita la razón como tal no
tenemos ninguna columna que me diga 12
ni ninguna columna que me diga 7 pero
como ya hicimos varios de estos
ejercicios creo que es muy fácil saber
hacia dónde vamos la relación es 12 a 7
así que si a este 12 lo multiplicó por
10 me da 120 gramos de brócoli habrá que
multiplicar este otro valor al 7 por la
misma cantidad para seguir teniendo la
misma razón así que vamos a multiplicar
la 7 por 10 me dan 70 entonces 70 gramos
de coliflor se comen por cada 120 gramos
de brócoli para mantener la misma
son una razón de 12 a 7 o de 127 vayamos
al siguiente renglón 720 porque tengo
que multiplicar al 12 para que me dé 720
bueno pues puedes traer tu calculadora
por acá y decir 720 lo voy a dividir
entre 12 y eso me va a dar 60 así que
para qué multiplicar al 7 por 60 para
obtener la misma razón voy a multiplicar
60 por 7 para seguir con la misma razón
y eso me va a dar 420 así que vamos a
escribirlo por aquí voy a poner 420 420
la razón 720 gramos de brócoli por cada
420 gramos de coliflor es lo mismo que
la razón 12 a 7 ahora tengo 490 porque
tengo que multiplicar al 7 para llegar
al 490 bueno si no lo sabes al igual que
yo me podría sacar de nuevo tu
calculadora por aquí y decir voy a
dividir al 490 entre 7 para ver qué
valor me da 70 70 por 7 es lo mismo que
490 así que si quiero mantener la misma
razón habrá que multiplicar a las dos
cantidades por la misma cantidad 7 por
70 es 490 y ahora me falta multiplicar
12 por 70 para obtener mi otra parte de
la tabla y eso me da de respuesta 840
por lo tanto lo voy a poner aquí 840
gramos de brócoli por cada 490 de
coliflor y ya está de nuevo tengo en la
tabla completa y sigo con esta razón de
12 a 7 así que es hora de comprobar mi
respuesta y de lujo estamos bien nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo